قدر حرصها على استهداف المجندين تحرص
الميليشيات الحوثيه على استهداف المسعفين
بالتزامن مع كل عمليه قصف صاروخيه نحو
مارب شواهد كثيره تؤكد تعمد الميليشيات
الحوثيه تدمير القطاع الصحي واستهداف
الطواقم الطبيه في اكثر من منطقه رصدها
تقرير انتهاكات حقوق الانسان بلغت اكثر من
2600 انتهاك منذ مطلع العام 2015 حتى
اليوم
بين اكثر في اكثر من جانب اللي هي المنطقه
همم
سيارات الاسعافات الطواجن الطبيه
التحتيه للقطاع الصحيه وقتل الاطباء
والممرضين
والاجهاز على الضحايا جرائم ومركبه
ارتكبتها الميليشيات الحوثيه راحه ضحيتها
مئه 39 طبيبا وعاملا في القطاع الصحي
بماربه خلال سنوات الحرب وتدمير مئات
المنشات
الاعتداء على اطراف الطبيه والكادر الطبي
بحيث نلاحظ جماعه الحوثي محمد هذا
الاستهداف لا اكثر من مره حيث تضرب مره
تضرب بالمره الاولى حتى تاتي الطموح همم
الاسعافات الطبيه وتقومبها وهذا ما يتنافى
معه القانون الدولي الانساني التقرير
الحقوقي الذي اصدره مكتب حقوق الانسان
بمارب تزامنا مع اليوم العالمي لحقوق
الانسان حمل الامم المتحده والمنظمات
الدوليه المسؤوليه القانونيه في
الانتهاكات الحوثيه مع تسبب مكاتبها
الرئيسيه في صنعاء باقات خمس حملات دوائيه
في مارب وكذا ايقاف الامداد الدوائي لمائه
125 مرفقا طبيا وح
2785 مريضا من العلاجات الخاصه بالامراض
المزمنه محمود الحميدي العربيه مارب